today on the matt walsh show we are told
that we must trust the medical and
scientific experts but what if the
medical and scientific experts
have gone completely insane and
abandoned the most basic medical and
scientific truths for ideological
reasons
what then well we'll talk about that
today also five headlines including some
good news from the olympics as
the women's usa soccer team continues to
lose which is great and the trans
weightlifter laurel hubbard
completely flops in embarrassing fashion
plus democrats panic as the eviction
moratorium comes to an end but should
there have ever been an eviction
moratorium in the first place
and we're also told that florida is in
the middle of a coveted crisis is that
true
we'll talk about the data that the panic
pushers don't want us to focus on and
finally in our daily cancellation fauci
don lemon ted lou and others all say
that you have the right to be free from
sickness
they're horribly wrong of course and
i'll explain why all of that and more
today on the matt walsh show
so you know we talk a lot about
boycotting companies
uh and and there's a there's a place for
boycotting especially the companies that
hate us as conservatives and are working
against us
um that that's one thing i think even
more effective thing
is to actually support the companies
that are on our side and
charity mobile is prime among them
charity mobile is the pro-life phone
company
that's because five percent of your
monthly plan price goes to the pro-life
pro family charity of your choice
you know other mobile mobile services
support
questionable causes and agendas but
charity mobile
they support the pro-life cause which is
the number one cause
in the culture um and it has been you
know ever since roe v wade switched to a
company that shares your beliefs and
won't cancel or sense will you censor
you for them
there's also a lot of other great perks
that come it's just a good company
all together new activations and
eligible accounts get a free cell phone
with free activation and free shipping
you get free usage alerts you get a free
app to monitor your usage pay your bills
and more plus there's no contract
there's no termination fees there's no
risk with a 30-day guarantee what does
that mean it means that you might as
well give it a shot
try charity mobile and if you want to do
that call them at
six six 1-877-474-3662 or chat with them
online at charitymobile.com
we are condemned these days for failing
to show the appropriate levels of
deference and obedience to supposed
medical and scientific experts these
condemnations could be heard loudly and
frequently enough even before coven
it was quite common during a discussion
about say climate change
that the skeptic would be shouted down
or simply dismissed outright on the
basis that he
isn't a scientist and therefore his
opinion has no merit of course
very often the people doing the shouting
and dismissing were not scientists
either
and yet they felt qualified to tell you
that you're not qualified even as they
continue to espouse their own views
with abandon um the standard cliched
refrains of you know
trust the science and listen to the
scientists and you're not a doctor what
do you know
have been utilized by intellectually
lazy people as a means of stifling
discussion and silence and criticism for
a long time
but in the age of kovid they're now
chanted like religious incantations
it's now not only a sign of intelligence
if you shut up and nod your head in
agreement
with whatever statements a doctor or
scientist makes it's also a sign of
virtue
skepticism is now a character defect a
form of heresy
the scientific experts speak infallibly
from their pulpits and anyone who dares
to contradict them
or even to ask for clarification or even
to say something like oh wait a bit you
said this before and now you're saying
this what
if you do that you're a blasphemer an
apostate
burn them at the stake figuratively for
now but perhaps literally soon enough
this is a problem because most obviously
the alleged
medical and scientific experts have been
proven wrong
so many times when it comes to covid and
besides
if you agree with what they're saying
now whatever that happens to be
that means you're disagreeing with what
they said a week ago
and if you disagree with what they're
saying now that only means you that you
still agree
with what they said a week ago it's not
actually possible to fully reject
the scientific and medical authorities
on the subject of kovid
because whatever opinion you hold has at
one point
in their opinion and it may become their
opinion again in the near future
the question is not whether you agree
with the experts
it's which version of the experts do you
agree
with do you like their recent work or do
you prefer their older stuff
maybe you're more of an oldies guy and
so you really love a fouchy classic hit
like
there's no reason to be walking around
with a mask on which he said way back in
march of 2020.
but yeah you can't do that we're told
the other thing about trusting the
experts
and listening to the science is that you
have to pretend
yesterday never happened each day is
the first day of your life you are born
anew with the sunrise
and all you are meant to do is reach out
your hand and clasp on to the coattails
of the experts and go wherever they lead
you
now some of us aren't willing to live
that way we're not able to pretend
that we're the guy from memento with a
memory that dates back no further than
47 minutes
into the past we look at the whole
picture
and we see the experts contradicting
themselves going back on their own
pronouncements
making determinations that are clearly
driven by politics
like when they all declared in unison
that it's not safe to eat at a
restaurant but it is safe for blm mobs
to gather by the thousands in the
streets
that you know you can't eat at the
restaurant but you can loot it that you
can do
now that alone the fact that public
health authorities
all made an exception for blm riots
during the height of the pandemic
was enough for reasonable and
intelligent people to permanently lose
whatever faith they might have had in
public health authorities
but it gets worse the real problem is
is what they're doing now and saying
apart from covet
see it's one thing to be cowardly
partisan hacks
as nearly all of these people have
proven themselves to be
in theory though even cowardly partisan
hacks can still be reliable sources of
medical or scientific information
some of the time at least but the
sickness in the expert community
runs much deeper than mere partisanship
the fact is that these people many of
them anyway
have abandoned scientific truth
completely
on the most fundamental level
after all what good is a medical expert
who doesn't understand or pretends not
to understand
basic human biology now i shared on the
on the show a few days ago i think it
was friday or maybe thursday a
disturbing report by
katie herzog published on barry weiss's
sub stack
about the intrusion of gender theory
into medical school we already knew that
gender theory had infected grade school
and four-year universities um
and but now we know that it's made its
way into medical school
which is no surprise but this is where
of course the next generation of doctors
are being taught
and now they're being taught that
biological sex does not exist
so let me read a portion of that report
again uh because it's important
so it said uh quote during a recent
endocrinology course
at a top medical school in the at the
university of uh
or in the university of california
system a professor stopped mid-lecture
to apologize for something he'd said at
the beginning of the class
quote i don't want you to think that i
am in any way trying to imply anything
and if you can summon some generosity to
forgive me
i would really appreciate it the
physician says in a recording provided
by a student in the class
whom we'll call lauren quote again i'm
very sorry for that it was certainly not
my intention to offend anyone
the worst thing that i can do as a human
being is be offensive
his offense using the term pregnant
women
quote i i said i said uh when a woman is
pregnant which implies that only women
can get pregnant and i most sincerely
apologize to all of you for that
it wasn't the first time that lauren had
heard an instructor apologize for using
language that to most americans would
seem utterly inoffensive
words like male and female why would
medical school professors apologize for
referring to a patient's biological sex
because lauren explains
in the context of her medical school
acknowledging biological sex can be
considered transphobic
when sex is acknowledged by her
instructors it's sometimes portrayed as
a social construct
and not not a biological reality she
says in a lecture on transgender health
an instructor declared quote
biological sex sexual orientation and
gender are all constructs
these are all constructs that we have
created in other words
some of the country's top medical
students are being taught that humans
are not like other mammals a species
comprising two sexes
the notion of sex they are learning is
just a man-made creation
now we should really stop and
contemplate
the sheer depth of
the cowardice here on display this is a
professor at a top medical school
someone who certainly understands
biology
understands that only women can get
pregnant understands that there is an
innate biological difference between
males and females
and that this difference is by no means
in any way a social construct
now he understands that and yet he is
too afraid to speak this truth to his
own students
when it is his job to speak that truth
for fear of being called transphobic
this is exactly like
a math professor who's too afraid to say
that five plus five
equals ten for fear that it might upset
those who prefer to live in a world
where five plus five equals
five thousand it is
exactly the same as that in terms of the
general insanity and the cowardice
involved
and it doesn't end with medical school
obviously here's the latest headline
on this front this is from webmd article
just published yesterday it says
remove sex from public birth
certificates ama says
the article explains quote sex should be
removed as a legal designation
on the public part of birth certificates
according to the american medical
medical association requiring it can
lead to discrimination and unnecessary
burden on individuals whose current
gender identity does not align with
their designation at birth
namely when they register for schools or
sports adopt get married or request
personal records
sarah may smith md delegate from
california
speaking on behalf of the women
physician section said removing the sex
designation is important for moving
towards gender equity
she said quote we need to recognize
gender is not a binary but a spectrum
obligating our patients to jump through
numerous administrative hoops
to identify as who they are based on a
sex assigned at birth primarily on
genitalia
is not only unnecessary but actively
deleterious to their health
okay notice the the language
that this doctor and a delegate for the
american medical association uses
she says that sex is assigned at birth
that is her medical language assigned as
if it's
given to the child by the doctor on an
entirely arbitrary basis
which is like saying when you go in for
a physical and they
they do your height and your weight it's
like saying that that's been assigned to
you
your height and weight measurements are
assigned by whoever does the measure
measurement
well i've been assigned six foot one too
bad i was hoping they'd give me
seven feet there goes my mba dream
this makes no sense obviously and
neither does the claim
that sex is on a spectrum
the people making these claims know that
it doesn't make sense
they are destroying the medical
profession from the inside and doing it
on purpose
and eventually the really scary thing is
they're going to give rise to a
generation of scientists and doctors
who repeat the same madness and yet do
not know that it is madness and i say
eventually
but that is happening right now as we
speak
and we're supposed to sit back and
simply trust
these people it is accurate to say now
that my eight-year-old kids
understand more about human biology
than that medical school professor
and many of the doctors who will come
out of that system
my children know more than they do are
greater experts on biology than they are
and that's why we don't trust the
experts
because we can't because they've all
gone insane
now let's get to our five headlines
now we check in with uh our very good
friends over at rock auto
yeah one of the big problems with going
to an auto parts store when you need
auto parts is number one you might have
to get into your car that might not be
working that's why you need the auto
parts but also
um especially if you live around where
where i live
and it's 7 000 degrees outside i think
uh you know
almost the temperature of the surface of
the sun almost and you got to get into
the car and it's super hot out why do
you want to do that just stay inside
your home
on your couch like the lazy slobs we all
are
and pull out your phone and go to
rockauto.com rockcotter.com always
offers the lowest prices possible
and uh you know that if you find it on
rockauto.com uh that's it it's the
lowest price you don't have to look
anywhere else rockauto.com is a family
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
you can go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the catalog is unique it's extensive
they got everything you could possibly
want
but also it's really easy to navigate
you can quickly find
everything you're looking for on
rockauto.com so go to rockauto.com right
now and see all the parts available for
your car
truck and remember i want to get credit
for this so write walsh in there how did
you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you well um
i it's big news i do want to start with
biggest news of all my wife and i
uh prior to this weekend we had never
been
to costco at all you know not together
not individually and i know that that
means we hardly qualified as american
citizens i think even legally you know i
don't even know if we qualify but um
but that's how it was we've never been
and then we decided on saturday that
we're going to go to costco for the
first time and that was going to be
um that was like our family event on
saturday that's what we did it's big big
big deal um you know when you're when
your parents
and you're married this this is what you
do on a saturday you go to costco
and so he did and now that i've that
i've been
and i've heard so much about this place
um all i can say is that that place is
dangerous
it is it should probably be illegal they
should probably all be
shut down forcibly by the government um
and i admit we made some rookie mistakes
like we went on the weekend
too many people it's like an amusement
park there's a line to get in the door
like an amusement park and then we
brought our kids which is a bad idea
and then also um i was hungry and you
know you know you never go grocery
shopping while you're hungry especially
at a place like costco
i i can see how you would save a lot of
money at costco in theory but in
practice
everything is more expensive it's just
that you get a whole lot more of it
but then the problem is do you really
need like a 50-gallon
whiskey barrel filled with cheez-its do
you really need enough baked beans to
fill a swimming pool do you need
you know a can of tuna the size of a
hubcap do you actually need that
do you need so much dijon mustard that
you'll have enough left over to bequeath
it to your children when you pass away
um i you know pound for pound gallon for
gallon the deals are great but then
again
if i offered to sell you a tuba for 200
that would be a great deal
but you're still out to 200 and you
didn't need the tuba so
it's it's it's like the the black friday
thing where oh you know all these great
deals i can get this toaster that
doubles as a remote control car
and it's only 35 yeah that's true but
you're out to 35 and did you actually
need that that's the question
so anyway long story short or long story
long
long we ended up spending i think 46
thousand dollars
and um we've already eaten most of the
snacks or at least the kids have the
whole the whole tub of jesus is already
gone
so it can work but you got to go in
there with a blueprint and a strategy
and you got to be serious about it i
think that's
what we learned all right so good news
from the olympics
i'd love to start monday on a good some
with some good news
rarely can we do that but we can hear um
first of all
the u.s women's soccer team lost to
canada
so in dignity on top of indignity not
only do they lose but they lost to
canada of all things
and that means they're no longer in
contention for the gold and that's
that's great news
um also this from the daily wire it says
new zealand transgender weightlifter
laurel hubbard competed and failed
monday in women's um
87 kilogram weightlifting at the tokyo
olympics
so i wish these measurements were an
american damn it under a kilogram i
think what is that uh
the two pounds is a kilogram i could be
totally wrong about that pretend i
didn't say it if i'm wrong
in hubbard's first attempt the weight
lifter tried to lift 120 kilograms and
failed
in the 43 year old second attempt
hubbard lifted a very shaky
125 kilogram as noted by one of the
female commentators it was very
surprising that the questionable 125
kilogram lift wasn't challenged with an
appeal
on the third attempt hubbard could not
lift the 125 kilogram
bouncing the weight lifter from the
competition
the announcer said quote uh that's the
end of laurel hubbard
as hubbard waved to the cameras and to
those of the competition
uh and so now now uh this this man
is gone and
that's good because he deserves to be
humiliated in this fashion
fashion because this is cheating
i don't i don't care what what the
insane official rules say
you're a male competing against females
you haven't you have undue inherent
biological advantages you know you have
those advantages
and you're using those advantages to
your benefit
and i would say that's cheating
and so so he so he lost but of course
what's happening now
predictably is that the left is saying
that this actually proves
that men don't have an advantage they're
celebrating this too
they say yes see you see there's no
everybody's worried about laurel hubbard
a man competing against women
and uh and she loses and so you see
there's no
you guys are you're freaking out over
nothing there's no advantage at all
yeah except that this was a 43 year old
pudgy out of shape dude have you seen
pictures of this guy
does not look like a weightlifter at all
looks like i could i could probably beat
him in arm wrestling okay
and um out of shape mediocre athlete
who couldn't come anywhere close to
qualifying against the men
then of course but it's just it's a
coincidence though
couldn't qualify couldn't hack it
against the men and then discovers
late in life that oh actually i'm a
woman well what do you know
that's a coincidence though i mean we
couldn't we could never accuse laurel
hubbard of
having this um revelation for
self-serving reasons even if it was
extremely self-serving it's a
coincidence that it's so self-serving
you understand
but out of completely out of shape
mediocre athlete
um of course he loses
but the fact that he qualified as an
olympic weightlifter in the first place
against women tells you everything you
need to know i ask you how many
how many pudgy out of shape 43 year old
females are qualifying as olympic
weightlifters
can you give me an example of one
this dude is competing against like 21
year old women
um who have who are you know talented
athletes
against their own competition and he
waltzes in there and it makes it onto
the stage at least
oh but yeah the the fact that this guy
this 43 year old guy couldn't win them
the gold medal
proves that men don't have an advantage
yeah you know what if i if i just uh
stumbled into the olympics myself and uh
you know
and was accepted as a female and i got
onto the track
against um the women in the 100 meter
dash
i would lose badly well that
was i guess that proves that men don't
have an advantage or it proves that i'm
just
slow and i have no business being there
and of course i would get beat
if you really want to know about the
advantages there's a website um
called boys versus women.com
boys vs women.com and the whole website
is dedicated
to comparing the world record times the
women's world record um times and track
and field events
against high school boys
and if you go down the list so basically
you have the best high school boy
um a child against the
best female athlete in the world
and if you go down the list for all the
track and field world records
the boy wins the boys win every single
one
except for the marathon
all of the others well over a dozen
close to two dozen
um the boys win handily
so so for example 200 meters just
pulling one example at random 200 meters
the woman the women's world record is
21.34
world record best woman female athlete
in the world adult
that was beat by a 14 year old boy with
a 20.89
okay and that's a pretty significant
difference
by the way the 200 meter dash 1500
meters
best female time women's world record
is um is three minutes 50 sec 50.07
and um that was beat by about two
seconds by a 14 year old boy
and you go down the list and you've got
14 year old boys 15 16 17 year old boys
beating the women's world record times
in every single
contest except one
oh but there's there's no advantage no
advantage at all
all right um moving on now the coved
panic pushers have
zeroed in on florida again uh they i
suppose they were never not zeroed in on
florida
but they tell us that florida is the new
epicenter
of covid uh there's a there's a crisis
an emergency in florida here's a report
from the cbs miami affiliate
um this report was published yesterday
it says florida is becoming the
epicenter and
as i read this pay attention to what
you're not
told okay florida is becoming the
epicenter of the chronovirus outbreak
and just this week cases jumped 50
with more than 110 000 new cases
reported
case numbers are now back to where they
were in january before the vaccine
became available
dr eileen marty said there is no higher
risk area in the united states
than we're seeing here the numbers that
we're seeing are unbelievable just
unbelievably frightening according to
the florida health department the new
positivity rate for all of
florida is at 18 percent in broward it's
14 miami dade it's 12 percent
monroe county is at 16 um
and uh going on i'm just skimming
through to see if we get this
information that i'm looking for
other hospitals like memorial healthcare
systems say they're overwhelmed
uh this morning we had over 420 patients
with coveted
55 are in icu and the icu 55 people
are fighting for their lives and only
one of them is vaccinated
um said a covet icu nurse manager
named joanna maja
and skimming through now you notice
what's missing here
what we're not being told um
how many people are dying that's what
they're not telling us
and this is the shift that i've been
talking about over the last few days
now you go back to the winter um
and for the year prior to that and
that's what that was the number one
thing we were told
is how many people are dying the death
rate
which which in a way is fair because
that is the that
you would think that's the most
important figure
how many people are dying because we
know that a great majority of people
get the virus they recover okay and
they're fine and we're not too worried
about that
so that's that's not the really
troubling when we hear um
unbelievably frightening
when i when i when someone tells me they
have unbelievably frightening statistics
about
a disease well then i want to hear about
the deaths because that's the
unbelievably frightening thing
if people are dying left and right
but if millions of people are getting a
virus and they barely even notice they
have it
and uh they have a headache in the
sniffles for a few days
and then they're fine i don't consider
that unbelievably frightening
frightening even if a lot of people
haven't
now if a great portion of those people
are dying that is unbelievably
frightening
except in this article and this is the
case in so many of the articles that
you're going to read about the covet
outbreak in florida
florida is the new epicenter florida is
doing horrible
they're not going to say much about the
deaths and
why is that well it's because not a lot
of people are dying in florida
so as it stands right now i'm looking at
the latest statistics this is the new
york times
far from a far right rag okay
and they're also not trying to do any
favors to florida but this is what they
say
seven-day average for deaths as of
august 1st 2021
is 58. okay that's the um
seven-day daily average of 58 people and
just out of curiosity i have to look it
up right now because i don't know what
off top of my head
what is the population of florida it is
21 million
so in a in a state with 21 million
people
on average 58 in the entire state
are dying it's sad when anybody dies
but 58 out of 21 million
and you know last week we kind of broke
this down we went through
the the major cities the most populated
cities in the country to look at
you know what their daily death rate is
and in a lot of these cities like in
chicago and other cities philadelphia
it's like one or two or zero
washington dc has not had a death from
covid
in at least a week they've had one or
two in two weeks
what about in florida we break it down a
little bit
and i will look this up right now just
out of curiosity
live on the air okay so look it up
miami okay just as an example
miami according to the new york times
statistics
has not had a death from covid since
what is this we'll call it
june 9th or 10th
so they've gone almost the entire summer
in miami without a single death um what
is the most populated city
in florida i think it's jacksonville i
believe
and uh let's see what about them
i'm looking at it right now they have
not had a death in jacksonville in the
entire city
since again early june let's say june
3rd or 4th or 5th
um you could go i don't know orlando we
could look at let's see orlando again
just a just a s the death line on the on
the graph
is just solid straight across
until you get back to again early june
so some of the biggest and most
populated most condensely populated
cities
in florida have not had any deaths at
all
for almost the entire summer
so that's the un that is unbelievably
frightening
and you know what it's true that that is
unbelievably frightening if you want the
pandemic panic to continue
if you're frightened of the pandemic
ending then it is
absolutely frightening that so few
people are dying i suppose
but to those of us who don't want people
to die and who actually
love and cherish life okay to those of
us who are not
deranged scumbags this is great news
this is this is great it's very sad when
anybody dies we know that people are
going to die every single day
in this country hundreds of people every
single day die very sad thing
but when you can look at some of the
most populated cities in florida or
across
the country and see that almost nobody
is dying from this
great wonderful news we should throw a
parade celebrating it
but we can't because it is actually
being mourned by by the coveted panic
pushers
all right next year the cdc's eviction
moratorium
has expired that was the rule passed
down by our overlords of the
cdc saying that landlords are not
allowed to evict people
who don't pay their rent now how in the
hell does the cdc have the authority
to make a policy how do they have the
authority to make any policy
let alone a housing policy well nobody
ever quite explained that
the cdc never explained where they get
this authority from but they found it
or rather they just claimed it that's
what tyrants do they say oh you know
that's what do you mean authority i have
the authority because i'm doing it
that's why i have it
um and so that was the policy had been
in place for months now and then it
expired
congress didn't extend it and now the
socialist wing of the democrat party
which is
otherwise known as the entire democratic
party is playing the blame game um first
here's aoc a few nights ago
in the middle of the night saying that
she was marching to the capitol to
demand that the moratorium be extended
uh this this i think is pretty
frightening this is kind of an
insurrection that she
you might say that she conducted on her
own let's watch this
hello from washington
it is about 11 24 right now
and i am walking to the capitol because
congress is allow is about to allow
the national eviction moratorium to
expire
at midnight tonight and
they're forced the moratorium to expire
before
the emergency rental assistance money
has gotten out
to renters and mom-and-pop landlords
and so i'm heading out over there
because sister corey bush has
called for us to come out there and call
on congress
to bring their buds back so that we can
vote to extend the mortality
it's not just me and it's not just
representative bush
but we've done a call and
lots of everyday people are starting to
show up on the capitol steps
demanding that we extend the victim
moratorium
because the alternative is to allow
almost 11 million
people to be at risk of eviction
starting midnight tonight
look at that that is uh that's that's
terrible storming the capital
an insurrection it's worse than 911
honestly um but it's the
the eviction moratorium she's saying
it's coming to an end people are going
to be
evicted it's going to be a crisis across
the country
and that might actually happen where
lots of people lose their housing
because um they've been told for the
last
many months that they don't have to pay
their rent and
and that was never gonna last forever it
couldn't last forever
and so by giving people waving your
magic wand
and giving millions of people the right
quote unquote to not pay their rent you
have set them up for this aoc
you've set them up for what's about to
happen
but we should say if she was on cnn
later after storming the capital and um
and
conducting this insurrection the
insurrectionist was on cnn
talking about this and she doesn't blame
the republican party she actually blames
the democrats let's watch that
democrats control the house you guys
control the senate you guys control the
white house
nothing aggressive was done by
leadership uh
until just a couple days ago who's to
blame here well you know i think there's
a couple of of issues here first of all
you are absolutely correct in that the
house and house leadership had the
opportunity to vote to extend the
moratorium
and there were many and there was
frankly a handful of
conservative democrats in the house that
threatened to get on planes rather than
hold this vote and we have to
really just call us beta spade we cannot
in good faith
blame the republican party when house
democrats have a majority
now there is something to be said for
the fact that this court order came down
on the white house a month ago
and the white house waited until the day
before the house
adjourned to release a statement asking
on congress to extend the moratorium
conservative democrats that's the
funniest thing i've heard
in several days a handful of
conservative democrats who are those
exactly
yeah it's concer every single democrat
that you will talk to publicly will say
you know for example that
men can get pregnant so that that that's
conservative now
conservative democrats uh but this is a
perfect example of the
faux compassion that you get
from the left and even a lot of people
on the right who who defend these sorts
of policies
in eviction more time if we could put to
the side the fact that the cdc does not
have the authority
to issue such a proclamation in the
first place
and it's it's kind of you know that's
the law okay the constitution it's sort
of hard to put that to the side
it's really important i would say if we
want to be a civilized
society um under under any kind of rule
of law
then then you can't really put the law
to the side but if we were to do that
and just talk about this thing on the
merits
this is horrific
um counterproductive
stupid morally deranged immoral
that you are telling people
that they must that they are required to
keep
people in their homes on their property
who are not
paying for the right to be there
that's what the government declared if
you're a landlord
um and there's someone on your on your
property in your home
who is refusing to pay you refusing to
compensate you
at all you must continue to pay for them
to live there
you got to pay their bills you're paying
the mortgage
you have to pay their rent for them
and allow them to stay on your property
that you know what that is that's
slavery that's forced labor
you're being forced by the government
to pay someone else's rent for them on
your property
it's like it's unthinkable and yet
millions of idiots will defend it
on the basis of compassion compassion
for who exactly
what about the person who owns the house
owns the property what about them
you're putting them underwater because a
big part of their financial plan here is
that
you know they've got to pay the mortgage
on this property
and so to help them pay the mortgage
then that's that's that's why the
renters have to pay it's not john
you know just to be clear it's not
because they're mean landlords
it's not because they're mean that
they're making you pay the rent
it's because they're providing you with
something with a service and you have to
pay in exchange but also
they need to pay very often they have
bills they have to they have to pay the
mortgage on this property
and if you don't chip in then now they
got to pay their own mortgage for their
home
plus this and however many many other
properties they own
so you are putting them in a financial
crisis
by not fulfilling your own obligations
and so yeah it's you know what it's
compassionate if we pretend
that the landlords don't exist that
they're not really people
speaking of forced labor and slavery if
we just pretend that they don't count as
people
then yeah it's perfectly compassionate
and and again the land yeah there are
mean landlords out there um
i i haven't i haven't rented in a long
time but with my experience with
landlords i had some good experiences
and some bad experiences
um so there are mean landlords out there
there are bad landlords sure
but it's still their property they own
it
and you don't have a right to be there
if you're not paying for it
imagine think imagine thinking that
someone else some stranger
is in tight you are entitled to stay on
their property without compensating them
you're entitled to it imagine walking
into someone else's house a stranger you
don't know them
and saying i'm entitled to be here no
you can't kick me out
because that's what you're doing you're
squatting you're a squatter now and you
are
uh trying to defend your right to
squat on this property without paying it
it really is infuriating
and uh and just so you know yeah there
are mean landlords out there there are
bad landlords
but not every landlord is some sort of
um
fat cat you know in his in his uh
office sitting on his leather chair
stroking his his uh
his white cat smoking a cigar laughing
maniacally about all the poor people
he's about to
evict from his property okay that's
that's not the case that's
that's not how all landlords are in fact
most of them aren't you know a lot of
landlords they're just normal people
you want to know a situation that
happens a lot and this is how you know a
lot of um
single-family homes that are for rent
you could have just a normal family
that moves from a house and let's say
they're not able to sell it or they
decide they don't want to sell
and so and they move into a different
house and they rent out the house they
just moved out of
these are just normal middle-class
families yeah there are plenty of normal
middle-class families middle-class
people
who are landlords
and but they don't count and now you're
saying oh you got to pay two mortgages
now
and if you're destitute because of it
that's your problem
and and also i i think it it it's uh
there's some bearing had this has some
bearing on this thing
that employers across the country
are begging for employees
okay there is not a crisis of jobs not
being available
employers are begging for people to come
work for them
offer you can get a signing bonus at
mcdonald's now
so who exactly are these uh
these millions of renters who simply
cannot pay their rent at all don't have
the ability can't get a job can't do
anything
while you've got employers begging
saying please come work for us we'll do
anything
but i know you have the you have the
right to say no i don't want the job but
i'm just going to stay here
and i'm not going to pay for anything
and you have to pay for me to stay here
in your house
yeah great compassion there all right um
let's see what else we got here chicago
under mayor lori lightfoot has
reinstated its mask mandate
um sorry it's guidance they're they're
calling it wearing a mask is
strongly encouraged for everyone indoors
this is because of a surge in cases
although the daily death rate from
covenant in chicago right now is i think
before i said was
excuse me it's actually two so the i
think i said it was one it's double that
it's actually two
so the kova daily death rate is two in
chicago two people dying per day
but now they're reinstating the mask
thing um
and yet lori lightfoot after reinstating
the mask
guidance decided to um
still have lollapalooza which is the you
know the rock festival
thousands of people showed up and now
now i
i seen and she was getting some
criticism for that and she should be
i see no problem in principle with
having lollapalooza
i mean have all the music festivals you
want live your life it's fine it's great
go to music festival
it's fantastic but when you're doing it
while telling people to wear masks
and you're not wearing one yourself
that's where the problem comes in
although it isn't as bad as dc where
they reinstated their mass mandate
full mandate even though the average
daily death rate from coveted in dc
again is
zero yes zero and yet even even after
mayor bowser put the mandate in effect
she officiated a wedding
without masks on for hundreds of people
and the day before that
she had she threw a birthday party a
maskless birthday party for herself
um so more more coveted hypocrisy there
other lol
lalapalooza news that i think is worth
mentioning
limp bizkit performed um kids you don't
know about limp bizkit probably for the
better
fred durst uh i think we have the
picture of fred durst
this is really important okay here he is
so fred durst
i i didn't even know he was still alive
but he is
just barely based on the picture that's
what fred durst of limp bizkit looks
like now
as he was performing at la la palooza he
looks like an
lapd homicide detective in like 1975.
or maybe a a track and field coach or
something
and everybody calls him coach creeper
behind his back because of certain
rumors that may or may not be true
[Music]
we're getting old in conclusion
um all right let's move on now to
reading the youtube comments this is
from
jacob nobles he says it's hilarious that
matt spouts off all of these scientific
facts about masks and vaccines
yet he can't even admit the fundamental
scientific truth
that trans women are women see i sense
that you're trolling jacob but i
i can't i don't know i can never tell
anymore that's the problem
um moose chuckle says matt this is day
three of me making you regret
saying sweet daddy walsh well i regret
nothing
and pretty bold of you to make fun of my
name with a name like moose juggle
um rebecca says i posted on social media
that i was a proud member of the sweet
baby gang now everyone thinks i'm
pregnant
thanks matt well what's what what's
wrong with that
um and sk says after your example of how
unsafe driving is i'm scared to ever get
into a car again
yeah i got a lot of comments like that i
was we're talking about this comparison
with driving and wearing masks
um and that's but that's the thing and
we'll talk more about this daily
cancellation come up in a second but
you don't there are there are so many
things you do in your life
that aren't really dangerous
but there are risks involved that you
don't even stop to think about you don't
you don't dwell on it
at all you just go about living your
life
i mean think about how many bridges you
have gone over without
calculating ahead of time the
probability that this might be a
bridge with structural integrity issues
you just don't think about those things
that's the only way to live and function
as a human being
and um and finally
rebecca says the pornography epidemic
terrifies me and the lack of freakout
about it
is pretty horrifying yeah well i
think the it's it's not freak out i
don't think we ever want people to freak
out about anything because nothing
constructive happens about that
but paying attention to it and what it's
doing to our children what pornography
is doing to our children
um yeah the fact that we're not paying
attention to that that is horrifying
especially on the right
because we know on the left it's all
hedonism all the time
but if if on the right we can't focus on
this issue or see that it's important to
protect our children from this then
i mean what hope do we have what hope do
our kids have
we've talked plenty today about the
tyranny of the cdc and other supposed
public health
authorities who are not authorities at
all on that subject anymore
and when we're we're in the midst of
this tyranny it's the perfect time
for ben's new book uh the authoritarian
moment to come out and for you to read
it it's now available everywhere
that you buy books pick up this book
authoritarian moment and learn how to
say no to an increasingly tyrannical
government
authoritarian moment is now available at
amazon barnes noble or any other major
bookseller so get your copy now and
leave a five star review
to let others know that this book is
definitely worth their time also
it might seem like a dream but lounging
with the hosts backstage has never been
more in your reach um you probably
haven't been
dreamt about that in fact if you have
been dreaming about us
then i'd prefer if you didn't show up
for this or at least don't tell us
because that's kind of creepy
but anyway we're giving away a free trip
for two to come hang out with the daily
wire host backstage here at our
nashville studios
where you can meet all of us you can
tour the studios tour the offices and
get a great swag bag of merch and watch
us debate on the show live you can even
come see my
beautiful studio which is literally a
closet that they have stuff me in
uh with no windows or anything and i'm
just here in the darkness and in fact
when you come
to the studio i'll just be sitting here
in the darkness hunched over
like some sort of beast that they keep
locked back here
um anyway you can see that as well it'll
be a lot of fun so go to dailywire.com
backstage and enter code backstage at
checkout for 25
off your membership so again head to
dailywire.com backstage with code
backstage for 25
off and now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
as we know dr fauci always has a very
busy schedule filled with tv interviews
so it's nice when he could take some
time away from his tv interviews to do
some more tv interviews and that was the
case this sunday
when he appeared on the show this week
on abc and addressed the skeptics who
object
to the cdc's new mask mandate and by the
way skeptics of the cdc's mask mandate
include the cdc itself which
as we've covered previously said that
immune people
don't need to wear masks and now they
say they do without ever providing any
data to justify the change
in any case fauci who agreed with the
cdc when they said one thing about the
masks
now agrees with them when they say the
opposite and he goes further he says
that if you disagree
you are infringing on other people's
rights listen
the fact is there are things that are
individual responsibilities
that one has and there are things that
have to do with you individually
which also impact others
and get the spread of infection that
we're seeing now
the surge in cases john is impacting
everyone in the country so although you
want to respect
a person's individual right when you're
dealing with a
public health situation and we are
in fact in a very sick serious public
health challenge here
with a pandemic with a virus that has an
extraordinary capability
of spreading rapidly and efficiently
from person to person
so a person's individual individual
decision to not wear a mask not only
impacts them
because if they get infected even though
they say it's my
decision if i get infected i'll worry
about that
but the fact is if you get infected even
if you are without symptoms
you very well may infect another person
who may be vulnerable who may get
seriously ill
so in essence you are encroaching on
their individual rights
because you're making them vulnerable so
you could argue that situation both ways
that's pretty impressive you have to
admit dr fauci was not content to simply
be wrong about literally everything he
says about science and medicine now he's
expanding his horizons
to be wrong legally and philosophically
too he's like a renaissance man of
wrongness a
jack-of-all-bull you might say and this
all may remind you
of the ranting and raving done by don
lemon on cnn a few days prior
which we played on the show where he
called for um vaccine passports and
claimed that unvaccinated people
don't have the right to use public
transportation eat at restaurants go to
their jobs but he's not trying to
infringe on their rights simply by
removing their ability
to do anything at all no he says that um
they're infringing on everybody else's
rights
by existing now the idea that you're
taking another person's right away
by unknowingly getting them sick
is total abject nonsense but it's also
the idea that lies at the heart of most
of these draconian policies i doubt
whether the people pushing and
stating the policies believe it
themselves but it's certainly
what they want you to believe they want
you to believe that you have a right to
be free from sickness
and anybody who makes you sick even if
they don't mean to
has committed some sort of wrong against
you they want you to believe
that it's your right for everyone else
to wear a mask
you are entitled to have everyone else
wear a mask they say and
and as far as that goes they're lying
probably the craziest form of this
argument came from congressman ted liu
who tweeted recently quote
you have no right to spread your
respiratory droplets on me on others in
public
and in businesses the majority of
reasonable americans are going to fight
the tyranny of the minority who insist
that they can leave their saliva
everywhere and we will win yes
that's what going out in public and
breathing
is now insisting that you can leave your
saliva everywhere
you have no right to breathe around
other people you have a right to be free
of other people
breathing is what ted lou says
this is that's the kind of statement
that
in another time in another place that
would get you locked in an
insane asylum that's the kind of thing
that that
clinical ocd patients would say
so let's begin with a very basic point
here if you are infringing on other
people's rights by unknowingly getting
them sick
then you have infringed on other
people's rights hundreds of times in
your life
every time you leave your house covet or
no covet mask or no mask
you are potentially infringing on other
people's rights because you could
potentially get them sick with any
disease you do or don't have
do or don't know you have i should say
if if you if you don't have the right to
put other people in jeopardy
by going about your daily life then you
don't have the right to go about your
daily life
ever at all period when you venture out
into the world and encounter other
humans in any context
you are putting them in jeopardy
theoretically you could get them sick
you could cause them harm some other way
driving is an obvious example that we
talked about
last week whenever you drive down the
highway you're putting other people
on the highway in jeopardy especially if
you're a woman
just kidding not really there are of
course undo or unreasonable risks that
you might take which may result in harm
coming to another person driving drunk
is one
another might be you know setting off a
pink smoke bomb in the middle of a
drought
surrounded by dry wood and grass as part
of a gender reveal party
leading to a wildfire that torches 20
000 acres and kills someone in the
process
that was a real thing that happened the
couple in that case face up to 20 years
in prison and that's probably fair
because the risk they took was extreme
and unnecessary
and unreasonable and their actions given
the context
had a very high likelihood of resulting
in disaster
the question then is whether a person
with no symptoms
who has no known contagious illness and
no particular reason to think he might
have such an illness
and who might even be immune because of
prior infection or vaccination
is somehow engaging in extreme
unreasonable potentially
murderous risk-taking by simply walking
out of his house
and down the street without a mask on
his face
if the answer to that question is yes
then again it must apply
all the time to everyone whether covet
is a factor or not
there is always a chance that you could
get someone else sick with an illness
you don't know you have
there is always a chance that this
unknown illness could be fatal
if we're not supposed to take those
kinds of chances with each other's
health
if it's an infringement on their liberty
to do so then we should never see
a stranger's face ever again in public
permanent masking is the only way
you know it is it is not unreasonable
for a healthy seeming person to go about
their lives
as every other healthy seeming person in
history through all time has gone about
their lives remember
this idea that you should just wear a
mask preemptively everywhere you go
even if you're not at any significant
risk of spreading or contracting a virus
is completely new humans have never
responded to a disease this way
and it's not because there weren't any
diseases
and yet if we don't adopt a radically
new approach to living
rejecting the way that everyone
everywhere for all time has lived
then we're not only wrong but somehow
we're we are the extremists the radicals
the ones who need to defend our own
behavior rather than the other way
around
what it comes down to is this and if
what i'm saying what i'm about to say
here offends or scandalizes you that's a
sign that you're hopelessly confused
so here it is you don't have the right
to not get sick okay
someone else's bare maskless face
can only be considered an infringement
on your rights if you possess
the positive right to be free from all
illnesses
but you don't have that positive right
you cannot have that positive right
you may as well say you have the right
to never die i mean sickness is an
inevitability of life
the risk of sickness comes hand in hand
with your membership in a human society
in fact
even if you separated yourself from
human society and all human contact
you're still going to get sick because
nearly everything you come across in the
physical world
is a potential transmitter of disease
and death
everything now it's not psychologically
healthy to view
everything that way or to dwell on it
but it's true
to say that you have the right to not
get sick is to say that everyone else
the entire world nature itself has a
responsibility
to shield you from an inescapable aspect
of reality
the idea that we have the right to not
get sick stems then
not only from an overwhelming
suffocating sense of entitlement but
also from the utterly deluded notion
that a sickness-free death-free
existence is potentially available to us
if we just take the right precautions
it isn't no such existence is on
offer for anyone sickness discomfort
misery death all of these will accompany
you through your life
no matter what you do they're always
going to be right there standing right
beside you
until they finally consume you and put
you in the dirt
again we may not like to dwell on this
fact but it is a fact undeniably
unavoidably with all that said
does that mean that a person who is sick
with a dangerous illness and knows it
um has no responsibility to take
precautions or avoid contact with other
people in some circumstances
no of course not you don't have any
universal
and inalienable right to never get sick
but that doesn't mean that someone can
infect you effectively on purpose
just as you don't have a universal
universal inalienable right to never die
but that doesn't mean that someone could
just walk up
and stab you in the heart so here's an
example of a form of viral transmission
that would constitute an infringement
and a crime
um or it should be a crime anyway if
somebody knows they have hiv
and they have sex with somebody else
without telling that person that they're
hiv-positive
okay there's an infringement but
incidentally in california
it is no longer a felony to do exactly
that in that state a law was passed
recently making it so that it is not a
felony
to knowingly expose another person to
hiv without their consent
to knowingly to do something with them
that you know is very likely to give
them hiv
and not tell them that is no longer a
felony
and of course that change in the law was
celebrated by the left especially by
lgbt activists
and as it happens these are many of the
same people who now say that you're
infringing other people's rights
by walking through walmart without a
mask
having sex with someone and exposing
them to hiv on purpose is all right
but standing standing by a person with
no known illness
uh you know in in a checkout line for a
few minutes without a mask on
that is that makes you effectively a
biological terrorist
that's the logic we're supposed to
accept and it's exactly backwards
and that is why the mask cultists are
once again
not for the first time not for the last
time
canceled and that'll do it for us today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day everybody godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audios mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright
dailywire 2021.
john bickley here editor-in-chief of
daily wire wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode governments across the
globe crack down on protests over
vaccine mandates and renewed lockdowns
school districts and lawmakers clash
over mass mandates
and police sound the alarm over police
reform
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire